so you can have two people experience  the same thing trauma same same  adversity and one registers at it as an  actual trauma and one doesn't right and  even in the same person there's  something called say the multiple hit  hypothesis which might say  that i might have three four five  traumas maybe and they could look pretty  significant from the outside but they  don't overwhelm my coping mechanisms and  change my brain as i go forward then  there might be another one that might  even be much smaller and that could push  a person into now having basically a  post-trauma syndrome so it varies by  person what are our genetics and are we  are genetics protective or do they make  liability for us what is our prior life  experience been what support mechanisms  do we have around us so it varies across  people and it can also vary within a  person might be that fourth fifth sixth  trauma that can then make a syndrome  that didn't occur with the first